[Music]
it's my husband he's gone missing
missing I'm terribly worried
it's just Fred's never been gone this
long before how long has he been missing
since the funeral well I can start right
away there private investigator my
profession is very complicated okay it's
nuanced you be people and charge money
yeah sad isn't it how much would you
charge to be my friend Janet what how
much you got 20 bucks that's good this
conversation is over
the mob is trying to spread its
operation to Los Angeles somehow my
daughter Mia is involved please find her
I've seen this girl what's in it for me
oh we can do this the easy way how
you're currently doing it the easy way
whatever happened to offering me 20
bucks it's the recession this is a
high-profile case made the newspapers
[Music]
[Music]
you beat up on me part of the job I
accept it but why did you do to piss me
off
[Music]
[Applause]
before we go solving the crime minute
century let's deal with the rotting
corpse get a plan I'm so sorry mr.
Connor I won't ever happen again I swear
to god you're talking to God see it
might as well swear to me it's Nicky
Collins town you're not gonna change
anything around here such
we're losing Los Angeles to Eastern
crook punt the future system a crime
wave its enemy occupation
I need you to wage war against Mexico
I'm looking to put a squad together
listen we small squad five maybe six
guys going up against 40 well you got a
die something leave these at home nobody
will ever know what we've done we're not
solving a case here going to war
[Music]
what's your racket answer I'm a Bible
salesman
I'm gonna take me away from all this and
make an honest woman out of me
no man I was just hoping to take you to
bed can't shoot me you're a cop not
anymore
fighting these bastards
[Music]
I have to finish this I'm looking out
for you
[Music]
it's not sales like a dog with rabies
you just got a bum down don't go Los
Angeles is my destiny is that right
[Music]
you're gonna be begging for a bullet
before it's over
[Music]
if I Drive for you you give me a time in
a place I give you a five-minute window
anything happens in that five minutes
I'm yours no matter what I'll see them
while you're running it down I'll carry
a gun
I Drive what do you do
I Drive movies a dangerous it's the only
point time you put this kid behind a
wheel don't want you to meet mr. Bernie
Rhodes
sure all mine he's in prison there she
doesn't want me to do a job for him and
I'm not gonna do it
I said she got there
[Music]
I'll tell you something anybody finds
out we're both dead that's why this
drivers got a go burn gotta go
[Music]
do you members any dreams you have or
plans for your future think you're gonna
have to put that on hold for the rest of
your life you're gonna be looking over
your shoulders of marriage and you have
nothing to say I'll just say it I slept
with someone if you keep talking I'm
gonna get out of the car I did it it
just shows how you're getting a divorce
yeah
Amy heard you crying in the bathroom we
all thought it was cancer oh thank god
relationship
[Music]
fine tonight while you drink let's get
out of here let me get out of here what
are you doing later
I do cuz that's a beautiful women in
this bar but I can't take my eyes off
you we gotta move
oh it's forward of you but ok should I
pull the car around you've been drinking
I'll Drive to the train your wife
cheated on you because you lost sight of
who you are as a man which take that
straw to your mouth it looks like you're
sucking on it okay you're sitting there
with a Supercuts haircut and you're
wearing a 44 you should be wearing 42
regular credit card where your wallets
[Music]
what you got to take control your
manhood pal you put on some clothes
please I'm sorry she's bothering you
beautiful I want to show you off to my
ex-wife speaker really Jeff I met a girl
and she is a game changer
she's your soul mate right go get her
back Wow how old are you I'm in love
with her and I don't know what to do
about it
[Music]
I don't know when you and I stopped
being us now when I told you that I had
to work late I really went to see the
new Twilight movie by myself but it was
so bad
you
say garnish why we take arbitrary
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
[Music]
two options you either follow my rules
or follow my rules
capice thank you I can do it a different
way oh that's that's fine thank you very
much
[Music]
your fire it's Christmas yeah I see the
decorations good luck in the new year I
[Music]
just heard you play and I wanted these
dreams that we keep running into each
other maybe it means something I doubt
it yeah you could just write your own
roles you know write something that's as
interesting as you are what are you
gonna do my own Club happen every time I
think so how are you gonna be a
revolutionary if it's such a
traditionalist you holding on to the
past but jazz is about the future
maybe I'm not good enough yes you are
maybe I'm not it's like a pipe dream
this is the dream it's conflict and it's
compromise it's very very exciting
[Music]
[Music]
it was a magical summer Noah was a
country boy
Ali was from the city they met the night
of the carnival they had nothing in
common but after seeing Ali that night
something inside Noah snapped with you
[Music]
they fell in love didn't it yes they did
you wanna dance with me sure this is a
good story I think I've heard it before
like a dream dunno I work at the
lumberyard how much do you make at your
job forty cents an hour it has got to
stop no he's a nice boy but he is not
for you see how it's gonna work you
won't not to see him anymore and that's
fun by Nicholas Sparks Oh miss how's
about that day comes a story it's normal
not to forget you first love but I want
you for myself by me about what we long
for I saw your picture in the paper and
I just wanted to see if you were okay
what we settled for I have a fiance
waiting for me what happened who did you
choose and who we're meant for why
didn't you write me I waited for you for
seven years
I wrote you every day for a year
New Line Cinema presents Ryan Gosling
Rachel McAdams James Garner general as
James Marsden with Sam Shepard and Joan
Allen in a Nick Cassavetes film I read
to her she remembers the notebook
[Music]
you
[Music]